all right Nisa is with us in Allentown
Pennsylvania hi Nisa how are you good
Bates are you remember well better than
I deserve
how can I help okay on my husband and I
in my sons we moved out of our rental
about two weeks ago had mold the
landlord was in to fix it and we moved
in with my parents they said we just
stay here about six months or so and my
question is during the six months while
we're here we're in baby steps - we have
38,000 and that - we save money or pay
off debt what should we focus on well
where are you going to move Oh doctor
Philadelphia which into Philadelphia so
it's not two hours away um so it's not
the big problem is I don't know sorry
I'm nervous
touch okay okay well you have to be
prepared for the move and the move one
mean you would make a new deposit on a
rental you'd have utility deposits and
you have to pay for the move those three
things all cost money right yes my
husband um really wants to buy a house I
know we're like you're not out of my
house you're broke and living with your
parents $38,000 and dad you know maybe
buy a house out of mine house is a
nightmare for you yes no you need to be
renting unless you're going to have beat
there are you gonna be debt-free within
six months I hope so
what's your helpful income um well why
not
my husband bring home three thousand
after taxes and everything home and then
I do freelance work so just depends how
much I work but I averaged about 20 an
hour um you know $3,000 a month is
$36,000 a year Yuto loan you were 38
thousand dollars in debt he makes over
50,000 a year but he's after taxes
insurance and everything like that he
only brings in about 3,000 or something
we're not thinking I mean you probably
need to address that issue but aside
from that simple math says you're not
going to be out of dead six months okay
I mean you're not going to make 38,000
during the six months much less be able
to pay it off yeah I mean their parent
and my husband's parents are they're
selling their house and they're gonna
give us about 15,000 towards on May June
around there as well and they said that
they would like to save that for us
positive a house they're not going to be
ready to buy a house then so you won't
be able to accept that gift unless they
modify the conditions of the gift okay
all right what about on should we you
didn't even listen you're going to go
buy a house stop this okay
stop it you do not need to buy a house
in June you're broke you're living with
your parents you have $38,000 in debt
you have a household income of 50,000 or
less and you do not need to buy a house
in June because they give you $15,000 so
you've got to stop that gift and say
either don't give it to me or let me put
it towards the debt so that we can
quickly get out of debt build our
emergency fund and save for a down
payment but you need to be debt-free
with your emergency fund in place and
then save for your down payment you are
at least 18 months from that probably
more and so when you move out of this
house six months from now you are not in
a position to buy a house do not buy a
house it's going to cause you problems
you're going to create a mess homes a
home ownership is a blessing but it is
not a blessing for broke people it makes
you broker that's why they call them
mortgage brokers you're going to get
yourself in trouble
so tap the brakes talk to the players
that are involved here everybody stop no
we're not doing this now then the answer
to your question is during the six
months what do you do you want to pay
off as much debt as you can but you also
have enough money saved to make the move
without adding debt so your moving costs
your deposits and that kind of stuff
that much you need to have saved up
during the six months and everything
else goes towards the debt during the
six months and that's the direction hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]